hey guys did you guys know that we have
a highlights channel I didn't know
little clips of all of our episodes
little bite-sized pieces you could send
to your friends maybe you want to share
a piece to your mom but you don't want
to hear the whole thing yeah all right
we can we get kind of deep but you can
send your mom that little piece and
bunny can we subscribe of course you can
subscribe oh yeah subscribe do it right
held hey [ __ ] highlights check it out
just like that we are back did you guys
miss all of us hi [ __ ] and [ __ ] owes
she got Mitch a Mitch have you heard a
male [ __ ] is a [ __ ] [ __ ] and
[ __ ] [ __ ] and [ __ ] yeah I'm not
mad I mean okay if you guys are mad
about it tell us we'll figure out
something yeah okay so for now they just
it's a working title Mitch's and [ __ ]
hey [ __ ] and [ __ ] like dude we
have I mean dude we have to take a we
have to acknowledge this point we have
so many male like viewers yeah what's up
babies I know they hit me up on DMS too
and they're like hey I listen and I'm so
proud to say that I listen I'm like
right that's right look when we start
doing live shows don't be afraid to come
out boys now don't be afraid yeah come
on yeah see see boses booty live in
action okay in this episode we got the
beautiful Gina so we got the beautiful
Jess keeping it all natural for you guys
if you're listening on the podcast go to
the YouTube and I have to wake up today
because I have a rash on my face will
leave me alone oh [ __ ] I was giving you
oh yeah we were like you look good it's
like I just have to put that out there
because we're gonna be like ill I didn't
even notice it and I'm literally four
inches away yes dude she's lush it's a
[ __ ] lie she's fishing for
compliments we get your hot okay
yeah diaper rash rash and then we got
the most beautiful bootylicious bows
next to us I was wondering if you're
gonna call me what if she called Gina
and Jess like butta phul and then she's
like then we got the hilarious
[Laughter]
a really good personality got a great
personality I'm so nervous
well and then we have the B media oh
thank you old ass [ __ ] - also a great
personality
yes all of the above thank you but I do
want to introduce our special guest
today who was down to come through and
just play with us
Edith uh and Edith actually works at
pornhub and when we heard that she works
at porno we're like what girl what do
you do there let's get into that now oh
dude me she brought us presents wait
yeah she gave us so much your hook did
yeah yeah we love you so you're doing
you I also have to say like how easy I
am and like like eat it I'm just gonna
like tell you I'm I'm the small minded
person no she's not
I am I'm small minded I'm very judicious
and all in the but I was like at the but
I think oh no pornhub this is a sin
against man and then eat it gave us
shorts and I was like yeah I love her it
works they worked on us look how cute
this is
uh yeah I'm easily bribed - so like
you're in for life now a whole bag full
of yeah wear this to church oh you don't
even know where that is been googling
that [ __ ] you're like oh [ __ ] it was
like [ __ ] no sturgis chicken but eat
it i'm so interested because you and
Gina have an online relationship not in
that way yeah but I know nothing about
you other than like you're the
supermodel so again if you're listening
on the podcast move it over to YouTube
because you got to see her [ __ ]
beautiful face
she's mad cute yes Gina is she hot and
she was like oh yeah yeah absolutely
with a great personality and sense of
humor - nice Graham is hilarious thank
you so much we haven't really gotten
into the funnies yet I'm excited about
that
so so let me know what do you do there
because people are gonna be like oh man
is she a porn star oh um so I am the
industry liaison okay
so I kind of like represent pornhub to
performers and performers to pornhub
kind of like
where's meaning like point stars or
people that are that have like amateur
accounts that are you know making money
off of their home video stuff like that
so I helped them with their I guess
experience on the site so you're telling
me that you have to search for amateur
porn stars like you're just on sites and
stuff and you're like oh man this girl's
doing it let me introduce her to some
times that's part of it and it's also
like I'm the face of one of their brands
model hub which is like their clip site
so it's like not paid it's it's not free
to view it's like you pay to watch a
clip and that's kind of new we launched
it like a little over a year ago
but it's kind of the program for four
models to make money off of clips that
they don't necessarily want out there
for free even though free Clips you'd
still do get at revenue yeah but it's
just kind of a different way of making
all right Bucky guys I'm gonna cut
straight to the chase yeah both why is
step-sibling porn so popular I have a
lot of personal theories everybody is
kind of like yeah that's kind of fun
like like everybody in the office is
like yeah pretty weird like we don't
know like there's I I was reading a
conspiracy
the other day about there's so many
pornhub conspiracies what's really
awesome oh my god now I know what I'm
doing this weekend yeah okay my favorite
one is that we like make sex dolls like
sex robot dolls and keep them in the
basement and I'm like that's so many for
one oh yeah and I'm like why why don't
we tell anybody that like yeah like
doing artificial ones that a
twelve-year-old come up with this
conspiracy theory are you guys selling
it was like I'm like I'm on but there is
a conspiracy theory that like somebody
like a higher up and pornhub is really
into like and says no that's why and
that's not why we don't know why I think
it's just everybody hasn't beat up his
complex and everyone's like looking for
a new taboo and that's the taboo okay so
I'm gonna give you my theory
either on the podcast or like on JK like
a few times my theory on it is that
people are very very lonely and the idea
of just like meeting a random person and
[ __ ] them like isn't it sexy anymore
they need to have some kind of
connection to that so for them steps
totally important it's like okay it's
not that weird but that person in them
have a history right so like it's sex
like romantic yeah almost like it's
romantic point like a romantic one
really romantic that's my theory on it
I'm telling you like people are just
[ __ ] lonely and they need more than
like you know like a UPS man that's
gonna suck your dick well I've never
seen that one before
I guess though it's probably there okay
yeah isn't it the rule like the 36
there's a little 3400 yeah if you can
think it it exists oh yeah absolutely
yeah I've messed it too it's very
[ __ ] limits and it works what's one
of your limit no I mean like what like a
box or like a paper mache or something
that's always it's it's everything I
recently watched the loin King the lion
oh my god awesome it's so funny they all
have like except for one of them who's
just wearing a shirt that says I am a
snake $5.00 really hit a wall I think I
think that point I would like help
produce it or something I highly
recommend checking it out like make it
little boy the original Lion King the
new Lion King and the wine cake yes it's
horrifying it's a panic dude oh I've
seen like screen shots with the
prosthetic or whatever face whatever on
secretary it's like a scary horrifying
yeah I remember those stupid hoverboard
things that were out have you seen those
like the hoverboard things that people
can adjust up around and there's a put
the wheels yeah yeah there's a point of
that too like the girls like on the
hoverboard backing up I thought your man
he was going like full speed on both
like on the hoverboard going back and
forth
but it's almost like Danny's a really
talented this is really cool cuz I can't
even stand on this [ __ ] yeah so you
didn't have a question for him yeah
so how did you even know that this was
like a career path for you what a good
and when did you know that you're like
this is so I used to be a grant writer
it's like if artists or museums want to
like submit a project to get funding
from okay granting bodies and I would
like to help them write that it's so
boring it's literally the most boring
thing you could ever do and I was like
this sucks
and I love porn I think it's really
funny I think that porn is like a really
special genre of entertainment where
it's like this own its own kind of genre
of Surrealism and it just exists in this
like super isolated world where people
are really able to suspend their
disbelief so I've always just really
liked pornography and I was like I
wonder if porn scriptwriter was a real
job and then I googled it literally like
is porn a real job and it was and there
was an opening did you go to school for
that like for script writing no no no I
mean I had been doing kind of like
copywriting and stuff like that for a
little while and I had done some like
erotica writing for like freelance stuff
I got and so I applied and I did not
think that I would get it and I was
living in Toronto and I lied and said
that I was living in the city where this
job was and and then I ended up getting
it and they're like so he can use her in
two weeks I was like there's no reason
why I couldn't oh I will see you in two
weeks and I moved in two weeks and then
yeah also like you know a little bit of
badassery yeah thank you like I want a
thing I'm gonna google it I'm gonna
apply I'm gonna you know write about
yeah whatever I gotta do to get my foot
in the door and then you're like great
now let's make it happen yeah it was
definitely like a really nice turnaround
where it's like I want that and like oh
it like kind of the universe was like
and here
you go so I was a porn scriptwriter for
about a year
what does that look like I mean what I
got imagine they're really much to this
policy really it's oh oh time 16 yeah a
joke I'm believing you right because
that's what I was thinking tall guys
hold on there's a lot in the scene
before it gets it's building the
relationship as you said some people
skip through the release I do I want to
just jump right to it
i I yeah I mean after I saw that you
know that one where it's like the lemon
tree they're stealing our lemon
grabbing [ __ ] yeah I love good titles
though it's like straight to the bike I
know what I'm getting like lemon
grabbing [ __ ] yeah what did he get you
got to yell lemon grabbing [ __ ] a
script usually so I was writing for
mostly browsers and then I wrote for a
few other sites like twisties babes
stuff like that so so it's their pay
sites like it's not like a tube site
like pornhub where people don't have to
pay anything to view all the stuff
unless that you subscribe to point up
premium it's like you pay a monthly fee
like Netflix so it's a lot more involved
like most scenes are roughly 40 minutes
and I would say like a good 20 minutes
of that or mmm 10 minutes
plot and dialogue and stuff like that
so that's what I would write and then at
some point I would write like cut to sex
hmm take it away writing samples yeah
yeah I wrote in a sample script that was
about a it was a grocery store where all
of the produce was shaped like dicks
she's hired
and then yeah and and they're like yeah
it's kind of [ __ ] like get on board I
did the girl get [ __ ] by the dick
shaped produce yeah well the thing was
she was like so horny because all of the
produce was shaped as one get one get
like okay relatable yeah and then her
she went to her manager she's like all
of the produce is shaped like dicks I
can't work oh my god I want you to send
me your videos like the ones that you
scripted yeah you're the dick grocery
one never got for this drop the ball
this is way too much production value
like we do not have that many eggplants
how did you get so comfortable like
being so open about all this stuff cuz
like for me to come out and be like I
legit watch porn was like not easy like
I was like kind of like going like oh my
god be so judged cuz like I grew up like
in a religious household and [ __ ] and
that's all bad
so for you where were you just like this
is I love porn and I want to be in it
and not in porn but like work in the
industry um I feel like I've been lucky
enough to grow up with like an extremely
chill environment like all my friends
are super super open and my parents are
extremely relaxed like hilariously
relaxed my mom I like I got I made it to
LA and she's like say hi to the porn
stars for me so so I feel lucky that I
didn't have a lot to unpack I guess when
it comes to my own sexuality and or even
just like admitting that sexuality
exists yeah because I very rarely feel
like I'm in a situation where I'm being
judged for that and also because I've
had so many wonderful experiences with
people over the Year who yours who love
and support me that you know when
somebody is weird
I'm like wow that's a you problem yeah I
mean problem you can sort that [ __ ] out
on your own that's always weird me out
and people are like I don't like my
boyfriend watches porn I feel like it's
cheating dude like it's just no yeah I
mean people can it's all subjective I
guess yeah yeah I mean look I'm gonna
say this my boyfriend can watch porn all
he wants boob like if I find out that
you're watching porn with women with
triple D's no has blonde hair really
that's not fair
i watch i watch porn with huge dicks all
the time that person i'm kidding it was
it was a cheap joke you know I mean like
I definitely like if your boyfriend's
watching porn like do that let him get
to watch that porn
stay in this relationship one of the
sweetest things was them
I had an ex-boyfriend who was white and
then I was traveling for a little bit he
goes you know I watched porn with girls
okay another question sorry I'm like
really nosy what are some misconceptions
that like we can I don't know learn from
that you can give us insight on about
like working for porn yeah I mean I feel
like there are a ton of misconceptions
about the industry I feel like a lot of
it is based around people like not
trusting sex workers to know what's
right for them and and that's really
frustrating that's a good answer yeah
cuz me I was like okay no when you walk
into the office it's just not [ __ ]
everywhere it's like a corporate office
yeah that is a huge misconception it's
like an extremely boring like
open-concept office building like I have
a cubicle which is hilarious people
don't even when I was when I was script
writing like it was like an office job
like 9:00 to 5:00 like gotta go to the
porn Factory
yeah I wanna see that wait the point of
office is it's like on the DL government
building and [ __ ] it's on more yeah it's
a weird about it
it's like a nine-to-five thing cuz you
know what five o'clock you get off of
work and you're hungry
oh you do when you're hungry beause you
pull out your hellofresh so if you're
hungry and you don't feel like you want
to go to the store get a bunch of
ingredients and figure out a recipe yeah
just get this delivered to your door
what I like is it's everything's like
fresh fresh produce and the recipes all
there and it's made in like idiot form
you can't wonder I was not raised to
like know how to cook Oh like I didn't
know how to season things I didn't know
how to chop things I barely know how to
eat it
I had to learned from YouTube videos
honestly or even like the measuring of
ingredients - yeah they tell you like
one cup of something I'm like how do I
know like how many vegetables to get to
make it to one cup like yeah they don't
tell you how many to use or like what's
the difference between chopping and
dicing we don't know like what's that
what's what is that throw those
questions right girl these are questions
I have to had to figure out over time
but with hellofresh
they have everything made super easy
they don't tell you exactly how to slice
it dice picture everything there's
pictures I was trying to make it look
like the picture at the end I'm like
presentation portioned out locally
sourced yes what do our listeners care
and they have dietary things too but
anyway it's for a limited time you can
get nine free meal nine free wine from
hellofresh by going to hellofresh calm
slash b tch nine and enter b TCH nine
wait see it again again for a limited
time get nine free meals hello fresh is
a lot for the bird person at hello fresh
calm slash b TCH nine and enter b TCH
nine delicious pull those titties up
ladies and
comfortably with third love I right now
I'm rocking a third love bra so us
really gonna do it
yeah George covered his eyes but Bryce
was just like yeah I'm here for a bright
assume it right into it I was really
gonna do it but no seriously I am
wearing a third love bra right now and
you know I have to be completely honest
the first time around that I got a third
love bra I didn't get my measurements
correct but as soon as I went back I got
to take a little survey and it said is
the star the straps too tight is the
band waist too tight or the cups blah
blah and I said yes no yes no and then
they sent me back the perfect [ __ ]
bra they fixed it on the first time they
fixed it and it's like you know even if
you don't know like exactly what your
measurement should be they're like nah
[ __ ] I got you and I appreciate that
because I don't know how to measure my
titties no I absolutely know so they
have more sizes and other brands rather
than just the band size and the cup size
they also have the strap size they have
half sizes like they they get you bro
and if they don't get it right the first
time they're gonna fix you up I've
experienced it all so you don't have to
go to another store where they're like
alright plop your titties out and we're
gonna pull out this tape measurer from
1807 and measure your breasts oh my
girlfriend used to do that and once I
she got sprayed by titty milk you I
always said you I I mean apparently it's
really good for your skin yeah let me
get pregnant give me a cup yeah
oh I was gonna have you suck it straight
from the source no but anyway it's
speaking of their love yes this is a
woman founded company so they know what
the hell they're talking about it's time
to stop wearing bras that don't fit the
right way or they're too big too small
get rid of those save some time save
some money shot from the convenience of
your own home and for everyone listening
right now their love knows that there's
a perfect bra for everyone so right now
they are offering you guys 50% off your
first and I was
[ __ ] just go sister love.com slash b tch
now to find your perfect fitting bra and
get 15% off your first order
that's third love.com slash b tch for
15% off today and I know you said you
look at you sometimes they're scouting
amateur people and you're lying like I
would like to I never Scout amateur
people I sometimes like when people are
already like really established I'm like
hey like what is your opinion on pornhub
and then talk about it with them because
a lot of people have like reservations
about you know the ad revenue model or
God or they don't know that we have like
a clip site that they can upload their
Clips so and then I help them with that
process or just kind of like if they if
they're like this is why I don't want to
be a part of this and work with them
with that interest um but it's not it's
never really like an an amateur model
it's definitely usually people who are
more established sometimes like if if
somebody's clearly like that's their
career they've like chosen that like
there was like that Carla a little while
ago who was like I want to be a friend
porn star it's like this is my destiny I
love it she got like some like press
there's only thought and then I was like
hey you know I can help you but it's I'm
definitely never like you know creeping
on somebody's Instagram I was like hey
you would be really good not my job okay
so then I guess my other question would
be like what is it like okay what is
kind of like a category that an amateur
person has started up in because you
know some of them kind of like really
follow up with their niche category like
what's a category you've seen that
you're like oh what's up with this but
people find extreme success in oh my god
like all over there are so many
categories on pornhub that I'm like well
that is great no judgement here there's
some weird [ __ ] out there definitely
like like all the there's a lot of
really intense like cosplay stuff now a
lot of like
like hantai asked saying cosplays
blowing like they're all about cosplay
and anime and stuff now like it's all
over Twitter now yeah I could be Jordan
Michael B Jordan is a big anime fan yeah
[Laughter]
oh yeah yeah I would suck miles a dick
just to smell smiles a big smell
probably like sexy chocolate so you guys
were saying that you guys had like this
uh like you guys had like this the soul
connection because you guys are both
going in on the same prett what is that
I don't remember so let's start off
because there is this guy that went
viral I mean he was like an absolute
[ __ ] weirdo like pyro for what you
don't know already so let's let's call
him the Tom Rick right so Rick Flint was
like okay if you ever saw a man that was
so like the most extremely closeted
possibly probably closeted gay ever he
was also extremely homophobic yeah like
really which also I'm like bunch points
are game yeah yeah yeah and he had like
super like thin everything he would you
just say like oh yeah this a guy you
introduced us to no never oh I don't
know I've profiled not like yeah profile
I think okay okay and he's always like
I'm [ __ ] rich and I'm a rock star and
I [ __ ] porn stars every day so he went
viral because people just always is that
not a troll account no I know he was
very serious in like Chrissy Teigen
found him and was like whoa and then I
was like like Psychopaths he's so
deluded like oh you just show us that I
think you know you sent it to us in the
group she did yeah yeah and then so it's
all connecting to me now
and then so like I would love to just
look at his profile and then he post
something like oh yeah pornhub is gonna
interview me on their Instagram live
yeah and I was like yo I gotta see this
because I know whoever inch like
interviews him is trying to get like God
but juice yeah I'm trying to get the
juice no you're lying and they're trying
to catch him in his line so I hopped on
to the pornhub live that day to see the
interview and then that's what I saw her
so you were interviewing him yeah okay
it was her point up aria yeah yeah so
they were doing the interview and then I
was cracking up because he they were
being so truly but he wasn't really
getting it he thought it was like I'm a
[ __ ] star Aria is like so nice just
like the nicest person and like
hilarious but like is like a nice person
and like I tend to get like caught up
and things so I was like but I whenever
I like went like a little too far we
didn't like they didn't want him to cut
off like I'm [ __ ] yeah yeah exactly make
him feel like he's yeah so the point of
it was to just call him out how he's
just kind of loony and then well he's
like he he had built up this thing about
like being like a billionaire that was
very clearly a lie and uh and it was
very obviously not true which is why
people were following him because it was
just like when when is this gonna come
out and he was just like a total [ __ ]
like a like racist homophobe yes just
like ridiculous and I mean I remember at
one point I tried to get him to like
show us his house and he like would not
he was like like I have people over and
I'm like yeah oh yeah I can show you a
little bit flip it it was just it was
like a one painting on a long wall and
it was like okay that's enough yeah I
was like okay like he was really secret
and it was it was the painting and it
was a kind of painting that you see this
like a shitty motel painting but they
just kind of hang up there from Ross or
something oh my god and then so now told
me that he was gonna be like mr.
incredible oh he said that he was the
new Iron Man oh yeah he's filming for
iron man like this
he's like so yeah but he was like but he
was just such a jackass to everyone you
know like yeah he really like trolling
I'm in the chat or something
people were trolling like everyone knows
he's not it's like everyone knows that
this is all [ __ ] like his facade is
complete [ __ ] right
and then afterwards that's when I found
your Instagram oh my god she's so funny
she's so cute so I messaged you I was
like dude that was dope by the way this
is like okay so it goes in another level
so I'm a group but I haven't checked in
a while but I was in this Facebook group
that's solely dedicated like these
people and knew about this guy for like
years like he's been around for years
there's a Facebook group about yeah like
people were just like ah cuz dude like
legit they found his real name his
address all his court papers of course
all the cleaners
wow yeah and then like I got so sucked
into that group
I was like hey you don't know me that
was [ __ ] hilarious
you want to check out this group really
quick that's how we bonded over this
weirdo is that oh my god like so long
ago actually yeah have been friends for
a year and you just met this morning
yeah cute so and then so we kind of kept
in touch right and then that's when I
was like hey let's do it and then what
is it like a month ago yeah you messaged
me you're like hey do you wanna go
through pornhub Awards lol you told her
yeah oh that's so cool yeah and then
like a couple weeks later I get browsers
official check mark would like to
message you what did you do opened up
Pandora's horn so we're going out you
guys will already see that we are going
to or that we went yeah yeah that we
weren't scared if they'll be scared I'm
scared what are you scared about him
just being a bunch of around a bunch of
confident hot people I'm scared because
my brain still tells me that they're
sinners but yeah I think about balls and
dicks and like I say I'm
it's minded I'm working you on
brainwashing by the church yes and I
also feel like there's definitely gonna
be people watching that are like also
kind of like you know like weird about
it but trying to be open with that and
like our speech I speak for y'all scared
I mean as long as you're like coming
into it by being like I want to support
and like this I'm like I want to support
these women who are like hot and
confident like that's all right like
everyone has stuff to unpack do you find
that there are a lot of people that like
get into porn and then they realize like
okay wait this isn't for me and they
just disappear um there are definitely a
lot of people that exit the industry
pretty quickly I don't have a lot of
experience knowing or working with them
like the people that I'm friends with in
the industry tend to be people who have
established yeah who are established and
like that's their career but there are
definitely a lot of people who like you
know do a few scenes or like do canning
for a little while and they're like this
is not my like passion like kind of like
any other job like you know I I was like
I don't want to be a barista anymore
like it's kind of the same thing yeah I
mean in theory it's the same yeah yeah
oh I was gonna say you know just while
we're still riding that train of like
what's going on um I think there's some
people I know that like while looking
for work they're afraid of going into
the cannabis industry even though it's
like booming right now because me yeah
because yeah I mean lot you asked me if
I would be willing to like because I had
a few places you're like they got
[ __ ] money right now it's I don't
know it's still federally you were
literally the fourth person I know of
that was afraid to go into the cannabis
industry because of like the
connotations around it so do you have
any worries about after you leave
pornhub like what's next um I think
about that sometimes I definitely feel
like like I love porn and like I love
pornographers and I really like this
community and I have a lot of respect
for it so I'm very much loyal you're not
really interested in exiting the
industry anytime soon well where I I'm
not I have no I'm like I'm like 24 so
I'm like
but-but-but if I were to be in a
situation where a potential employer had
a problem with that I'm not interested
yeah it's the same thing as dating like
if they have a problem with something
you you don't need them either
yeah how has been how has your dating
life been with I mean not just in
general yeah when you because I mean oh
oh you guys are you lonely take my
parents I can't show you my parents
should happen definitely people have
been like and we're similar yeah I
definitely have had like a couple of
situations like that where I don't care
yeah sounds like a you problem but I
mean I've been very single for I was
like you're so so that hasn't really
been a problem yeah but I don't know
maybe maybe when I do start seeing
somebody more seriously and they have
issues but again it's one of those
things where it's like if if they have a
problem like they can unpack that and
that's not something that I think it's
not your problem with yeah like a lot of
people think porn stars especially like
the ones who've been in industry for a
while or so she's like [ __ ] like
Haggard and a druggie in real life and
blah blah blah whatever and then I'm
sure that's not the truth so that's
definitely not a true I feel like it's
the misconception it's so funny to me
because I'm I'm really in this isolated
world of like people who are like
extremely like a sex worker positive
like a lot of my friends our porn stars
so like I feel like I'm really isolated
and then I when I step out of that and
see people's like weird delusions about
like what porn stars are actually like
what like porn stars are like some of
the smartest most interesting people
I've ever met
it's really bizarre and like obviously
like any other kind of entertainment
industry like there are some like there
are like [ __ ] parties you know like
it's like people are partying and it's
also like you make a lot of money really
fast like that kind of thing
like any other initially like
professional basketball or someone yeah
but it's like you don't see people you
know weeping about professional
basketball players doing it's like so
it's like okay like where is that
concern actually coming from you know
people don't believe that porn stars can
have perfectly normal lives it's like
that's a job yeah yeah they can go
grocery shopping without trying to [ __ ]
an eggplant every day yes can't figure
that [ __ ] up dude like um there were
people that were messaging me like
saying like you know your friends are
[ __ ] porn star and battle-ax is she's
like and she's never done anything good
in her life like oh my god the moment
you find out someone's a porn star you
just treat them like they're inhuman or
yeah it's so for some people especially
those that were raised like very very
Christian for like 10 or 15 years like
their entire foundation is built off of
that this thing is bad in this thing not
maybe it's more its secret and so for
somebody to take it and completely strip
it of what you thought was sacred and
profit from it yeah it it violates
something in you they you didn't even
put there but it's there yeah you know
like and I think that in like because
you said your parents grew up like very
free-flowing and stuff you know I don't
I think it's like it's hard for me to
like know how you see it but it's hard
for you to see like how I see yeah
exactly but I also do believe that this
was a belief that was imposed on me and
hammered in um and it's the same for
other people so like even though I'm
actively saying like I'm small-minded
like I'm traditional and like I'm trying
to see pass it it's still hard so for
the people that haven't even accepted
that it's time to move past that and
they're like you know it's it's never
gonna happen no more super aggressive
about it too I'm like yeah I don't care
though you know why do you care so much
however a year you've been really good
because at one point she was terrified
of us even showing us her showing her
our tits yeah I had to like literally
chase her around like topple with your
titty yeah she would run from us yeah
and then like we took it to a spa like a
Korean spa where everyone like oh like
it's a female side so yeah the women are
naked we were all naked it was her first
time she's like oh
yes and now she's going by herself she's
telling us she's like y'all making us
[ __ ] here right now I'm butt naked in
public and I mean that was just two
months ago so like I'm literally like
actively taking steps to undo what was
taught to me and it's still a really
really really long process yeah well
it's hard yeah yeah that's like I would
never understate how difficult the
process of unlearning what truly society
at large has ingrained in you and just
like just acknowledging that that's
something that you're working on
unpacking is like huge like that's
massive and that's a step that like I
would say the majority of people don't
get to thank you um but right now we're
gonna take a quick little add a little
add break I had nothing for you Bose
yeah that's right how about we talk
about you fixing the messed up teeth on
your own ladies and germs I spent years
of my life with my teeth crowding in the
front and I thought everything was fine
however my overbite was jetting over by
the day and your teeth are constantly
shifting I know you had braces when
you're 14 but your teeth keep moving you
25 get some candid how can I get candid
so yes let me give you a little more
info on that I love the the personal
experience there because I actually had
that too I had braces actually I didn't
wear my retainers they shifted back yes
you're right Bose it does completely
shift but candidate liners can help
straighten your teeth faster than
traditional wire braces treatment can
take just up to six months on average
and for everyone here uh so it says I'm
gonna have a photo ready smile by the
holidays yes I'm bringing up the
holidays again because we are in them oh
we can imagine finishing your candid
treatment and then getting some white
strips doing it all yourself for a low
price and having a brand new smile by
December yeah so Bose you can go to
candid co.com slash b tch and use code b
tch to get seventy five dollars off
that's candid co.com so good / b tch
code b tch for seventy five dollars off
and a yes girl candy
co.com slash b tch code B am I wrong I
feel like whenever I look at other
podcasts they're like well you know just
go on and buy the product and we're like
$75 off yeah you get you get I think you
always get the most surprised with all
the the codes that we give all our
listen that's right we're giving back to
you all right for all my single people
out there looking for love I got the
answer for you baby today we're gonna
talk about our sponsor hinge I'm super
excited to talk about and this is
something that I'm kind of a little bit
jealous for all you single people out
there Arlis I'm jealous no because I
would have been nice to get on it after
like a breakup of fighting shitty people
in person and then just having a tool to
filter the [ __ ] and keep quality you
could have had more options exactly
that's why I'm jealous girl now you're
on my page I have so many options well
because you know we're in the great city
of Los Angeles but also hinge I feel
like hinge kind of makes all the best
people come together based on the way
that the profile is set up so what I
like is that you actually have to
interact with their profile a little bit
before you can start talking so it's not
like that weird creepy vibe of like
every guys just like messaging you hey
hey hey hey hey just like they didn't
even yeah and they didn't even like look
at your profile or read it or like oh
you have to have some substance to a
conversation so like they'll have to
like respond to a photo or like comment
on something that you put on your
profile for the conversation to get
started and I really like that because I
feel like people are actually talking to
me because they want to get to know me
yeah so yeah it's actually designed to
not be a hook-up app like a lot of
people think of dating apps and they're
like oh it's just people wanting to hook
up and it gets a bad rep and people get
really discouraged but their motto
unhinge is designed to be deleted so
they want you to find somebody get in a
relationship fall in love and delete
that app I love that I love it they're
not trying to keep you there yeah like
no stay we did the numbers it's more
like nah bro we don't care about the
numbers we genuinely want you to find
the one yeah yeah if that's what you
want also if you just want to have sex
then maybe you don't need hinge but if
you want love or maybe if you
sex with substance yeah I that's what I
I think that's kind of where I'm at
right now so I don't know how soon I'll
be deleting hinge I might be breaking
their rules who little I know just kind
of see what all the options are because
this is a very large city yeah
from what I've from what I've heard cuz
George and Bryce the guy that you never
hear then we never talk about but he's
back there yeah he's right back there
and he's single lady yeah he's hit on
him he's got a profile he's over 60
what's your profile name is it just
Bryce what honest yeah you gotta be
honest but no so he showed me his
profile and like you guys were able to
put like six pictures up it's not just
one picture and then you get to like
that's run quacks yeah fun facts you
answer questions about yourself and then
you get to see how important these
things are for you like religion if you
like to consume alcohol or drugs maybe I
mean I haven't played with is there a
vegan option um I don't know I don't
even I don't even great I just ignore
anything this is vegan sorry vegans yeah
yeah um no so it looks really freaking
cool like like I'm a little bit jealous
y'all like I shouldn't get out of that
relationship she's holding what if
there's someone better out there Hinch
I'm gonna get on here there check it out
dude yeah I'm with you Bose I didn't
grow up as religious as as you did like
I was lucky enough to have my parents
like listen to their kids a little bit
more use a little bit more logic not
that people that are religious don't but
I'm just saying like they they get kind
of fanatical and I don't know weird [ __ ]
starts happening but at least for my
parents my mom was very strong in her
beliefs and she prays every single day
like my mom if you feel her she's just
like this aura of just like holiness and
I can't imagine having to explain it to
her now being like I'm like you know so
closely related to point I don't think
my mom would understand that yeah you
know and she's and and she's very
supportive and she's kind but like even
with me like just how I grew up like I
still kind of have
to fight that in my own head where I'm
like wait why do I care about this why
do I fear this like why am I afraid of
sex or why am I afraid to like show my
titties like that you know yeah um so I
can't even imagine like you growing up
in the Bible Belt like part of wherever
you grew up Virginia yeah yeah and then
like show your titties yeah that's
amazing that's amazing cuz it's like
conscious that you have to tell yourself
no bows like there's two bows it's like
it was my bra so that's huge raw breasts
absolutely not okay my bad you know when
Gina was talking about how people get so
angry about it I think it's because like
if the Ten Commandments tell us this is
bad and like there's almost no degree
with that stuff like murder is on the
list but it's like also adultery and
this and people love to go after
adulteress they love to go after like
murderers they also love to go after
people that violate their laws of sex
that we're told to them and I think part
of it also makes them feel better about
they want to be righteous like I don't
want to be right exactly it's like are
you trying to save someone are you doing
this because you want to feel better
about yours well I mean and and the way
things are taught to it's like you're a
bad person you're going to a bad place
so of course you're gonna want to do the
right thing because you don't want to
burn and [ __ ] an eternal [ __ ] yeah
for everybody yeah set me on fire [ __ ]
I mean like it's I remember being a
child like I remember the room I was in
and everything we're like I had done
something bad I think I had said a bad
word and I remember laying in this room
with like AC on and crying because I was
going to hell what's with the ACA though
I remember I remember the way the air
felt remember like my thoughts I
remember like how I was curled up on the
couch Wow
and I was like I'm going to hell you
know and like that's the kind of mindset
that I was raised with so like yeah
there's a lot of people that are very
similar to me that haven't even you know
opened up that box and said okay let me
poke around here and see what's in here
yeah intimidating yeah sorry to get all
like no that's like a really good I
think
perspective to have also it's it's one
that I so rarely get to like speak with
that's because yet a people are like
even if they feel that way they don't
want to be honest
with me about it because they're worried
that I'll be like mad or something I
thought and and B I just like I'm in a
extremely kind of a religious like super
lefty like community of people that that
did not grow up with those experiences
also in in Canada I feel like there's
less of a Bible Belt situation there's
still there's still religious intensity
but it's it's just it doesn't have that
kind of fire but I think American
religion has hey can I get a tour of the
pornhub office one day I probably you
can see my my desk where I keep like my
collection of ramen noodles I really
want to a porn set like a ride-along oh
yeah oh my god it right along hop [ __ ]
of course she called it a ride-along
she calls it a ride-along I also want to
know and I don't know if this is too
personal but I'm just curious what your
favorite porn category is like oh yeah
you don't share too okay um I what's my
favorite cutter I mean I love parody
stuff like when I was writing it I
mostly did parody I did a lot of Food
Network porn parodies happening yeah I
know it was like once you get on that
train like it's hard to go off you know
hello but you still get off or like
because it's Swami and like or even if
you wrote it if you have you gone back
and watched it and been like yeah mine
are my own snow no I'm like too in it
yeah dude I already know it everyone
else's category is that's why I'm asking
I think I talked about it or for a
category that I think I'm like that's
hard
probably threesome nope oh wait which
girls one guy two girls weren't are you
guys too many days oh really yeah two
guys one girl named we're four guys one
girl or sixteen guys one girl okay
that's a different category
yeah that's your number two category
what's your second best my second best
um
amateur is a category I feel like
because I work I've done so much work in
like high production value porn
it doesn't really like do it for me like
with all the cameras so you have
whenever I watch an amateur I'm like
[ __ ] turn lightly yeah now I'm into it
now that I'm with you I'm all about
amateur like when your college dorm I'm
like no you're not but keep pretending
like this is my girlfriend I'm like ooh
like for some reason my brain says like
oh this is passionate but I know it's
[ __ ] not because they know that they
know they have the camera on but yeah
I'm with you on it yeah me and Jessa
lawyers can [ __ ] color correctors you
know they get a ring light yeah like
she's like wins the next dick come in DJ
Khaled what about me what
what's your category latex what's might
know it changes a lot so I had my I have
phases mine changes - yeah I have a lot
of phases so yeah I was really into
latex just cuz I'm like I have to have
the perfect perforins and I don't want
to see any blemishes and it just needs
to be perfect um and then sometimes I
like like orgies but then they have to
look really hot I'm such a weird like
they have to look perfect I hadn't
worried where everyone looks hot yeah if
I see exactly if I see a blemish on my
to reel I don't like it yeah I see like
a pimple on their bow no yeah bothers
the hell out of me yeah you know you see
like marks are you that's not my thing
sorry yeah so I guess that's my category
good call
if they're really [ __ ] hot and like
like unrealistic I'm like I want that
unrealistic buttocks with you guys
category that's called hot guys [ __ ]
so it's all I got used up [ __ ] dudes
like you they're all I'm not letting
stop dude I don't like Jack are you
happy
her husband though her husband's kind of
like jacked did you say the part was
juiced up no Jack let it build yeah I
like that you know like a silverback
gorilla yeah I want people that I feel
like to break me oh I'm such you I
recently discovered humiliation we like
in generalization correlation yeah what
it goes a lot of difference back
sometimes it's public humiliation like
what does that look like they pull down
her shirt let you know but I but you
have to guess what mine is cuz I'm not
gonna tell you because we just said I
literally know there's there aren't
their visual houses why humiliation yeah
it's like oh very white there's like
small dick shaming there's pissing no
okay no not like that
Jesus Christ if you want to I guess
we're going to go your mouth no they're
no scary or like emotional humiliation
yeah are you embarrassed that your
Christian guilt has turned into I I
actually think it's because I I'm a
sensitive person but I don't understand
what I don't understand my feelings they
my feelings come from extreme human
emotion from other people and so if I'm
watching something like pornographic
like if I can tell where the person is
like very sad or very happy I'm like I
like this very sad really I'm beer I'm a
very empathetic person so I have to
siphon emotion from the only thing that
I do oh no I remember how I told you
guys there's a dude that got turned on
whenever I cried for him it's like she's
not my birthday means ever
to me and you put this birthday together
and then like he doesn't show up and
you're crying and he's like [ __ ] yeah
that's probably oh it wasn't ever about
him making me cry I was crying he just
was like oh like you're like yeah it's
not true yeah what do you see that's
really bad oh well I thought it was like
he was like turned on by her feeling
yeah yeah I used to it and starts crying
lumpy dying right now do you know what
to do I'm so hard that's very concise
I've been into uh what into what what
the girls know this I mean it's like
really like like near not near okay I
want to [ __ ] almost die okay yeah
okay I like really rough you know why I
think my humiliation thing is you kind
of like like the physical masochism
I like emotional math emotional I don't
understand I'm not getting this out you
brought it up I know my boundaries right
even though she yeah I mean was like
emotional emulation it's just like it's
like dirty mean dirty talk I feel like
it's a big one or like like a lot of a
savior thing like there's a lot of porn
about like Oh like I'm lost on the
highway and my car broke down and I'm so
sad for big ass eyes and eyelashes is
really selling this yeah I love it I
love my god I don't have a driver's
license but my car bro it's about
realism but yeah the swoops in and like
she's like crying and he's like take my
jacket
Wow cute yeah ripped writer that's
that's not humiliation so much but that
would I would say like that's like an
emotionally charged
yeah humiliation I'll tell you guys
after this yeah yeah yeah and then we'll
tell you guys after I don't like cuz I
I've considered doing porn because I
love porn so I was like well why why
don't I just do it but I am too
sensitive is why I would match I would
subscribe and pay for your preview yeah
what do you mean like you would get
involved like attached I would I don't
yeah I feel like I get [ __ ] I'm
gonna be like like every day I'm like
when are we moving into super sensitive
to like on a scale of 1 to 10 how
sensitive are you like I'm like a good
eight nine oh wow really I would say I'm
an eight I just like to give you context
literally this morning I like took an
uber back to my like like where I was
staying and like this the Sun was coming
up and I was listening to like Lana Del
Rey and I did cry okay last night
obviously I was on the couch and I
watched a video and it was Ariana Grande
surprises fans yeah and she ran out on
one fan and one thing was so happy to
see her I cried I was yeah I was like oh
there was one right before it where it
kick-started the tear ducts and the
second one she was so happy I was like
yeah like I cry during commercials
that's awesome we're not her dude and
like I'm sure there's other very
sensitive people that are watching like
I had to learn like my sensitivity is
actually a strength yeah it very much is
but in order to get through the day to
day I have to like you know how people
say like protect your energy like I
really do you know I I have to protect
myself constantly because I am very
sensitive how do you do that um just
like if you know what you said was like
really powerful when you were like you
know you unpacked that on your own with
sensitive people like when those bullets
come at you and somebody says something
at you you have to like stop it and say
like okay where is this coming from okay
this isn't me move on because if that
bullet hits if that hits me
it [ __ ] stinks for like a long long
time and like I can't handle that I
can't go through my day-to-day soaking
up other people's pain like if I'm in a
room full of people that are just very
emotional or if there's a lot going on
or there's a bad mood I could be
perfectly fine and I'll soak up their
feelings like I feel ya know and I hate
that [ __ ] and I can't go I can't I can't
stall my day because of other people's
feelings feel like you're the same way
too yeah I definitely feel like for me
it's been a lot of like like this is the
first time pretty much in my adult life
that I've been like dating casually
which is I don't love it just because I
am so sensitive so I'm like really like
constantly and and like when that
vulnerability like isn't met or like
isn't shared or matched then I get like
really what age of men are you now I
gotta go protect you [ __ ] they are it's
just like I like in casual dating I you
have to be careful and especially like
where I live there's like a real culture
of like casual like arm's length stuff
which I'm like why am i dating you if I
can't be vulnerable right that's why I
date so I guess and I and I don't really
like casual sex and like that's very
like of the norm where I live so it's
just like like when I'm seeing somebody
and I and I can't kind of sense I'm like
I just don't think this is gonna like
this person's gonna match me where I am
then just like cut it off like like
learning not to like fall for an
expectation that that person has given
no sign of meeting that's [ __ ] so
mature of you I was like I must be right
I mean I still have those moments do but
then I'm like I tell myself is wow
really good I wish I knew that when I
was 24 Jesus Christ man now if I don't
get a text back I'm gonna look like him
jump off a bridge classic but I
he's very like what are you now gonna
open up like a picture fellow sensitive
girl yeah what do you look for in a guy
like what also really sensitive like I
want somebody that like if I was like
let's go to Las Vegas and get engaged
after like two weeks of dating they'd be
like yes wait wait create like a rider's
I like what rider yeah rider I
passionate which is also like not like I
I would not say that this is mature of
me I think this is I'm like looking for
like level 10 all the time so like that
but mostly funny that's like all I care
about I'm like if you're funnier that's
so you would date a complete ogre ugly
ogre if he was funny and sensitive I
would date was pretty low so I feel like
your options are very thank you so much
I mean I don't know a lot of guys are
like why do you want to date so low
compared to your own so thank you I mean
yeah I mean if you're offering me up
like a hot funny so yeah person right
now I'll take it I will take okay so you
don't have any qualms with dating
attractive people oh I have no qualms I
would just really don't like dating
attractive men I mean like overly
attractively you're like all right like
you know that like you know boy yeah
what yeah I still don't get it I want
six but I mean no but I think I think my
boyfriend is like a good 7.5 like to the
public but then I think to me he's and
that's all that [ __ ] matters there's
I think I develop that and I was like
okay I can't date super attractive
people because I was recently not
recently I'm sorry
like years ago maybe like nine years ago
I was going with this guy who's a male
model and he was like beautiful like I
remember rolling over looking and I'm
like damn he even sleeps beautiful but
that is stressful it's stressful because
one whenever we had to get ready he
spent way more time around the mirror
than I did and two it's like man like
this guy has a lot of skin care products
and made me feel like [ __ ] and three
like guys like that they know what
they're about you know and he was like
super male model like [ __ ] both
chicks and dudes male model I mean I
don't think we don't want somebody I'm
dating to be hotter than iron I think
when I was younger I was like oh he's
beautiful I want to date him like I'm
status like hot guys hi Guys hi guys but
I realize later it actually came from a
place of me having such low self-esteem
that I wanted arm candy I wanted the hot
guy to like be like to show off like
yeah I might be a [ __ ] 5 but I got a
10 so yeah and a lot of guys do that a
lot of unattractive men with money can
date the hottest women because it's like
their trophy and then as I got more I
think as I got more confident I was like
looks don't matter as much I don't need
the arm candy I just want a guy that I
[ __ ] vibe with you know the other day
with she oh my god guys she'd gone on
four dates with this guy and finally
they like they [ __ ] and she said it
was a were section 31 year old virgin
and I'm like we just wild to me because
I would think that all guys over like 26
27 at least kind of know how to fall
yeah I think all guys know how to [ __ ] I
think they just don't they think they
missed the like connecting with that
person and making sure that it's like a
dance really what they don't offer them
she the kissing was bad so she should I
would say kissing is really hard it's
hard to find a good kisser like three
guards if I've kissed a lot of guys I
don't [ __ ] them but I've kissed more
than I [ __ ] for sure and I feel like a
good kisser is hard to find who teaches
you how to kiss no one teaches you I
think if you if like in high school you
have to go through that phase of like
just making out with your first
girlfriend for like yeah you're straight
and a lot of guys miss that and like a
lot of guys don't actually sit there and
make out like in middle sit on for hours
and hours and hours until their face as
well to learn how to do it I want to
know what's the worst sex you've ever
had
oh that's such a good question
I've had some bad sex why don't we all
um I think that the worst this is I am
like still friends with this man you
didn't even have to say that now he's
like I'm a hundred percent sure but I
think the worst sex I've ever had was
somebody like we had been kissing for
like maybe three minutes
like maybe and kissing was bad so you
know oh yeah and he like that's a good
indicator very rapidly undress like yeah
like like really like scooted out of his
all of his clothes I was standing and I
was like watching him because I was like
and then he so he didn't even try to get
you naked at all it was just him first
he scooch out of him I'm picturing you
guys making on he's like one two I'm and
but I was like okay like oh I'll follow
the lead yeah I guess so I was like but
then he just sat I was literally
standing now standing there just like
that I'm like somebody oil paint this
cuz a table so we were both completely
naked
I was standing just looking he was
sitting on his couch leg spread just
with a with a boner
yeah and just like looked at me like
expectantly and I was like sup dude yeah
and I was like okay and so climbed on
for like maybe three minutes
and then I was like hey I got off and I
was like I I have to go wait what was
wrong with it like so what was what it
was just a whole situation cuz I was
like at no point like turned on ER
before he even got on you already wanted
to get off but yeah well I was kind of
just like I'm like for me like either I
have
because I have feelings for them or I
sex with somebody because it'll be funny
[Laughter]
likes comedy I love I love and live for
the bed this was like I'm like well like
I I just have to see it through
yeah and then I did and I was like okay
okay it was just the environment was
like fine also there was like he was
like trying to maintain eye contact I
was like I don't like that like don't
look at me don't respect me and like oh
like a really bright room I'm like at
the time I was a script writer at the
time okay did you know this is a
terrible job I feel like that might have
like played a role he was like she works
in porn she's gonna know what she's
doing I'm just going she's gonna I was
like surprised [ __ ] I have no idea what
the [ __ ] you're doing
please please write this into your
script and produce it I would love all
my script where it's like that it's
really bad sexy she leaves yeah and she
[ __ ] another dude and it's good oh my
god yeah I like the uber driver who's
like driving her home and I love that
we're gonna we're gonna end it on that
that was like such a perfect highlight
tending EDA thank you so much for being
here it was very insightful to get like
some some like back behind the scenes
like info on like what really happened
and just like what people can expect and
kind of like how you view it like it's
kind of like a bar Easter job a little
bit where you kinda have to like do
stuff and figure out if it fits you if
you if you like it keep doing it if you
don't ya don't do it exactly I love that
I know that also can I just say bro like
my own personal opinion make sure you
guys give us five stars on iTunes cuz
but good I was just thinking the the
conversation we got from like pornhub to
bad sex bad kissing why people don't
like poor and like we hit we we hit it
boys also it is if you guys want even
more comedy and some incredible
engineering by the way please follow
Edith on Instagram it isn't what she's
won
and then we're gonna stick it somewhere
in the bottom yeah make sure to
subscribe hit the bells rate us give us
five stars thank you again eat it so let
us know what's your handle my handle is
all underscore de underscore breakfast
underscore Oh make sure you guys check
her out the whole the whole like
paperclip thing has been I've been I've
been getting into engineering
thank you [ __ ] and [ __ ] bye